interesting news out of Poland were an
anti-abortion initiative gathered four
hundred and fifty thousand signatures in
support of a total abortion ban there's
been a parliamentary commission out
which as a result of these signatures
started to analyze a total abortion ban
meaning no exceptions for rape or incest
or health of the mother it's at least
been slowed down somewhat by these mass
protests that resulted from the initial
four hundred and fifty thousand
signatures the largest were on Monday
just a few days ago when thousands of
women turned out in Poland dressed in
black for people who don't know Poland
already outlaws abortions with
exceptions for rape incest a badly
damaged fetuses or when the mother's
life is at risk but because of the
culture around abortion in Poland there
are already doctors who cite moral
objections and they won't even perform
the few abortions that would be
considered legal in Poland and very
often Polish women end up going to
Germany or other countries or buying
abortion pills online which is of course
less than ideal when really they should
be able to just find these services
locally in a way that is not going to be
stigmatized or or concerning to anybody
uh yaris law Gowan who's a member of
Poland's Conservative government and the
minister of science and higher education
said that the protest by women have
quote caused us to think and taught us
humility uh that's good there are a few
stories here for me number one is that
hey if people work together and activate
you actually can make a difference and
influence government which sometimes is
really hard to believe especially in a
country as large and sort of
ideologically diverse as you know as the
United States it's hard to imagine a
protest really getting the attention of
government now we this is not dead in
the water in Poland but they are at
least thinking about it in a more
detailed way before moving forward but
the other aspect of this is that the
world is actually moving to the left on
abortion there are still many parts of
the world were abortion laws are very
backwards and retrograde but increasing
we even in relatively historically
conservative areas that oppose abortion
there is a louder and and more sort of
uh present pro-choice movement and I'll
show you a map here of abortion laws
around the world and you'll notice that
the real areas of concern are the Middle
East and parts of Africa a lot of Africa
really other other than than very
southern africa uh and significant areas
of concern also in south of South and
Central America uh and this is this is
why this really matters I mean there
needs to be an understanding that you're
not going to be able to just say hey you
know what it's just illegal it doesn't
matter if there was rape it doesn't
matter if there was incest it doesn't
matter if there's an issue with the
health of the mother but that's just not
going to fly and and I'm hopeful Rachel
I don't know if this is going to be the
case but I'm hopeful that the idea of a
total ban on abortion will in five or
ten years seem flat out inhumane more
than it does already right but I think
also a lot of people are asking the
question kind of why now for instance
when the Soviet Union fell in 1989 and
these second wave feminists were kind of
met with this staunch opposition from
the Roman Catholic Church okay that's
then but why is this happening now why
in Poland you mean or wide world wide
we're seeing a lot going to the left on
abortion of a favor you're favoring or
opposing abortion why in Poland now uh
right no I mean I think the real
question is why in Poland now did we
first see four hundred and fifty
thousand signatures gathered to ban
abortion altogether because that really
was the catalyst for the counter protest
and I actually don't know the answer to
that I mean we know that generally
speaking the religious right groups are
better organized and they will create an
issue out of thin air and force opposing
views to have to coalesce and activate
but it's an absolutely fair question why
now uh and I don't know the answer to
that but if you're listening and you do
let us know and we will let you know
what ultimately does happen with this
exploration of a total and a complete
ban on abortions in Poland we will take
a break i'm on twitter at dpac
men will be back after this Warby Parker
is offering a free five day home try-on
to give you the opportunity to check out
their glasses i personally wear Warby
Parker glasses when I'm not wearing my
contact lenses and I also started with
one of these free at home try ons of
five pairs of glasses you can get your
free home try-on and support the david
pakman show at Warby Parker trial
dot-com / tdps I don't really like going
into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home try-on I was able to pick
five pairs that i liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I like the most and then Warby Parker
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com / TDPS it costs nothing